OKAY UP GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
CALLING ON THIS HEARING TO ORDER
WILL -- STARS A SUB COMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE DO NOT YET.
HAVE A QUORUM MR KILEY IS
PRESENTING A BILL IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE.
AND HE WILL BE JOINING US A
MOMENTARILY -- SO ALL OF ON
CALLING THE ROLL -- WE HAVE
THREE BILLS ON THE AGENDA TODAY
INCLUDING ONE ON CONSENT.
THE MEASURES ON CONSERVE THE
MEASURE CONSENT IS AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE WE TAKE UP
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY MISTER
KALRA EACH SIDE WILL HAVE A
TOTAL OF SIX MINUTES. FOR EITHER
TWO OR THREE WITNESSES BY PRIOR
ARRANGEMENT WITH ME.
THIS COMMITTEE ALL OTHER SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION MAY LINE UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AND STATE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY -- SO AGAIN EARLY STE
IT'LL BE -- SIX MINUTES ON EACH
SIDE TOTAL -- WITH.
THE THE DESIGNATED NUMBER OF
WITNESSES -- WE HAVE A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDING TODAY WHO
IS SENSITIVE TO LOUD NOISES AND
WE WOULD REMIND ALL PARTICIPANTS
TO SPEAK AT A CONVERSATIONAL
TONE.
AND NOT YELL OR CLUB OR MAKE
OTHER LOUD NOISES WITH THAT WE
ARE READY TO BEGIN WITH OUR
FIRST AUTHOR AND THAT'S ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE MON -- SHE MAY COME
FOR TO THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible] ONE AND SHE IS.
COMING UP TO PRESENT -- AB TEN
SIXTY TWO MUSLIM ON YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY.
I ALWAYS START OFF BY ASKING FOR
THE MAYBE.
AB FIFTY TWO WILL HELP HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR AN EXIT AND EXPECTED
DISASTER A YEAR AGO MY DISTRICT
EXPERIENCE ONE OF THE MOST
DEVASTATING FIRES IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY WHICH WAS.
PRECEDED BY A MASSIVE DEBRIS
FLOW. FOR US FLOW DUE TO HEAVY
RAINSTORMS THIS STRATEGY
RESULTED IN MULTIPLE LIVES LOS
IT ALSO LEFT MANY PEOPLE AND
FIRST RESPONDERS STRANDED DUE TO
ROAD CLOSURE CLOSURES ASSOCIATED
WITH DEBRIS FLOW AND FLOODING.
THE TEEN SIR CONCEPT WAS CREATED
TO ADDRESS PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE CAPABILITIES FROM
WITHIN HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
AB TEN SIXTY TWO WILL PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN TEAM COMMUNITY
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAM CERT
BASIC TRAINING AND RECEIVE
CREDITS FOR COMMUNITY SERVICE
HOURS REQUIRED FOR GRADUATION.
TEEN SIR TRAINING WILL TRAIN
STUDENTS AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND BASIC RESPONSE
AND ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
SKILLS NEEDED TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND ASSIST WITH
OTHERS.
OTHERS IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY -- I A WE WERE GOING
TO HAVE AYE CHRISTY FAMILY HERE
WITH AT A CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS BUT
SHE'S TRYING TO GET INTO THE
BUILDING TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY HAS REVIVED.
THANK YOU US ARE THERE ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
A SINGLE OTHERS ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY I DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
REMOVES ALL SECOND IT AND WILL
HOLD OFF UNTIL SUCH TIME AS WE
ON A QUORUM BEFORE WE TAKE A
VOTE ON THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE A FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO I BELIEVE IT IS.
AND THAT'S YEAH AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SIX MISTER KALRA.
HE IS SOMEWHERE
-- MATTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TO ESTABLISH WARM.
CAN I SHOW YOU ARE.
GOOD.
O'DONNELL.
HERE O'DONNELL HERE KILEY KALRA.
KALRA HERE MCCARTY SMITH SMITH
HERE WEBER.
WEBER HERE.
WE DO HAVE WE DO OF COURSE IS
ALL.
CALL THE COMMITTEE HEARING.
AT SOMEBODY OCCASION COMMITTEE
HEARING TO ORDER -- MISTER KALRA
HAS -- FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS AB. FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU ALL FOR WAITING
PATIENTLY FOR MISTER KALRA.
WHO HAS NOT SHOWN UP?
WE WON'T DISSECT THE REASONS YOU
REALIZE.
BUT WE DO HAVE A BE.
WITH YOU BEING LATE.
IT WAS REALLY BAD.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE. FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO SPEAK WITH ME
ABOUT THE BILL TAKEN TIME TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE VARIOUS
TYPES OF DIE SECTIONAL CHART IS.
THERE A WIDELY AVAILABLE AS I
ALSO WANT TO THANK A NUMBER OF
YOUR STAFF MEMBERS WHO TOOK A
LOT OF TIME OUT TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THAT AS WELL -- AND AYE
AYE LASTLY LASSEN ABSOLUTE BIKE
BUT THE COMMITTEE STAFF -- A LOT
OF WORK WAS PUT INTO THIS IN IN
THE RESEARCH AS WELL -- ELASSONA
THINK THE NUMEROUS TEACHERS
RESEARCHERS ADVOCATES WHO HAVE
TAKEN THE TIME TO ENGAGE WITH ME
ON THIS BILL.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT AN EASY
TOPIC AND I'M SYMPATHETIC TO
CONCERNS RAISED AS TO THEIR
APPROACH THIS MEASURE TAKES.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX WITH
ESTABLISHED REPLACING ANIMALS IN
SCIENCE EDUCATION REYES ACT.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS REPLACE ANIMAL SECTION
WITH THE CONTEMPORARY
ALTERNATIVE FOR A MORE HUMANE
TEACHING METHOD.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED A AYE AYE
UNDERSTANDABLY -- QUITE A BIT OF
ATTENTION AS OF LATE SO I LIKE
TO MAKE CLEAR.
THAT IT DOES NOT BAN DISSECTION
AS A METHOD OF SCIENTIFIC
EDUCATION -- ON CONTRARY WILL
HELP TO EXPAND ACCESS TO MORE
COST EFFECTIVE HUMANE
ENVIRONMENT RESPONSIBLE METHODS
OF DISSECTION OTHER THAN ANIMAL
DISSECTION.
I AM NOT I SECTION HAS BEEN.
A PART OF TEACHING PEDAGOGY FOR
SOME TIME AND IT MAY VERY WELL
PEAK THE INTEREST FOR SOME
STUDENTS PURSUE A CAREER IN
SCIENCE AND MEDICINE.
HOWEVER OVER TIME HAS BEEN USE
LESS AND LESS IN THE CLASSROOM
INCREASED DIFFICULT CHALLENGES
AS A HOW TO STUDENTS AS HOUSING.
AS TO HOW STUDENTS RECONCILED
HUMANE TREATMENT OF ANIMALS WITH
THE PRACTICE OF SCIENCE.
AND RENEWAL BY MAIL PERSPECTIVE
ON THE COUNTER FOR TO TALLY THE
NUMBER OF ANIMALS USE AND
ANNUALLY NUMBER.
IN THE MANY THOUSANDS AND
PROVIDES A CLEAR PICTURE OF BOTH
THE FISCAL IMPACT TO SCHOOLS AND
MPACT THE SOURCING THESE
ANIMALS CAN HAVE.
ON THE ENVIRONMENT.
AS WE KNOW A STUDENTS ARE A
PRODUCT OF THEIR ENVIRONMENT.
AND ARE FAR MORE ABLE TO
NAVIGATE LEARN THROUGH
TECHNOLOGY -- THAT OUR
GENERATION AND GENERATIONS
BEFORE US.
EDUCATIONAL ALTERNATIVES PROVIDE
GREATER ACCESS ON A MORE
ENGAGING OF ALL STUDENTS THAN
CURRENT DISSECTION METHODOLOGIES.
IN FACT WE NUMEROUS WE SHIP
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN.
AS DEMONSTRATED ALTERNATIVES
RESULT IN EITHER COMPARED OF
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE INSTRUCTIONAL OUTCOMES
FOR STUDENTS.
AND THERE ARE AT LEAST THIRTY
FIVE STUDIES -- THAT HAVE SHOWN
THAT COMPARABLE OR BETTER
OUTCOMES IN TERMS OF THE
INSTRUCTIONAL OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS AND THAT'S REALLY THE
GOAL BEHIND EDUCATION.
ADDITIONALLY IN THOSE SCHOOLS
ALTERNATE HAVE BEEN USED THEIR
PROVEN TO BE MORE COST EFFECTIVE
AND HELP INCREASE STUDENTS
INTEREST AND PARTICIPATION BY
INTEREST IN REDUCING
CONTEMPORARY METHODS OF THE
CLASSROOMS.
THEY GIVE ALL STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE AND
BE MORE ENGAGING THE HANDS ON
ACTIVITY I CAN INSPIRED EVEN
MORE STUDENTS TO DIVE DEEPER.
INTO SCIENCE.
BY ADOPTING A CONTEMPORARY
HUMANE METHOD STUDENTS CAN HAVE
A BETTER EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
CAN BE A COST SAVINGS. FOR
SCHOOLS AND THE LAST CENTURY
DETRIMENTAL -- TO TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND TO THE ANIMALS.
WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY OUR DOCTOR
DON FORRESTER WITH THE FIT THE
PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE.
MATTHEW DUNCAN -- WITH WITH THE
ABC UNIFIED AND NICK
PSYCHOSOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION [inaudible]
FORCED.
ALL RIGHT BERMAN YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE THE THREE WITNESSES TO FIND
IT SIX MINUTES TOTAL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE IT BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME IS
DON FORRESTER.
AND I'VE PRACTICED IN CALIFORNIA
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS.
I COMPLETED MY FAMILY MEDICINE
RESIDENCY IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I'M A GRADUATE OF THAT
AMOUNT HEALTH CARE'S ADVANCED
TRAINING PROGRAM IN QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT.
MY EXPERIENCE AS A CLINICIAN AND
THEN QUALITY IMPROVEMENT LEADS
ME TO STRONGLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX BECAUSE OF
OUR FUTURE DOCTORS AND
SCIENTISTS DESERVE SCIENTIFIC
LEARNING EXPERIENCES THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE AND COMPASSIONATE.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE NEARLY
EVERY MEDICAL STUDENT IN THE
UNITED STATES INCLUDING ME WORK
WITH LIVE DOGS AS PART OF OUR
TRAINING.
OVER TIME THESE ANIMALS HAVE
BEEN REPLACED WITH MORE
EFFECTIVE REALISTIC MODELS.
THESE ADVANCED TOOLS INCLUDE
MANIKINS SIMULATORS AND PASS
TRAINERS INVOLVING HAPTIC
FEEDBACK.
THE FEELING OF REAL TISSUE WHICH
CAN BE USED REPEATEDLY TO ENSURE
APPROPRIATE KNOWLEDGE AND
MASTERY OF SKILLS.
ANY FOR PHYSICIANS HAS COME A
LONG WAY SINCE THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES TWENTY FOR BIOLOGY
STUDENTS.
SHOULD BE NO DIFFERENT LOOKING
BACK I WOULD HAVE BENEFITTED
MORE FROM THE NEWER TECHNIQUES
AND THAT AYE SECTIONS IN MY
BIOLOGY CLASSES IN JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
R. K. TO TWELVE STUDENTS CAN
BENEFIT USING SOME MORE
EXPERIENCES AS WE NOW USE THE
MEDICAL TRAINING INDEED I
BELIEVE THEY MUST.
POSITION TODAY REGULARLY USE
SIMULATORS COMPUTER PROGRAM
VIDEO ASSISTED TOOLS IN THEIR
DAILY PRACTICE SCIENTISTS USE
TECHNOLOGY TO GATHER DATA AND
OBSERVE THE WORLD AROUND THEM.
WHILE NOT ALL STUDENTS WILL BE
DOCTORS AND SCIENTISTS EVERY K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENT OUR STATE
CAN BENEFIT FROM IMPROVED
BIOLOGY.
TRAINING IN BIOLOGY AND WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB FIFTEEN IT IS TO
FIX.
THEY WILL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW DUNCAN AND I
AM A BIOLOGIST A. B. R. A
BIOLOGY TEACHER.
AND TAUGHT FOR THIRTY YEARS IN
THE ABC UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
BECAUSE OF MY EXPERIENCE AND
BACKGROUND IN SCIENCE EDUCATION
I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU MY
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SIX THE REYES ACT.
BECAUSE TODAY'S STUDENTS DESERVE
A SOLID.
MODERN SCIENTIFIC LEARNING
EXPERIENCE.
THAT IS COMPASSIONATE AND
ENGAGING.
WHEN I TAUGHT A P. BIOLOGY WE
USED DISSECTION AS PART OF OUR
LESSON PLAN?
AND DISSECTED RATS.
DURING THIS CLASS IT WAS
DIFFICULT.
OR IT WAS CLEAR THAT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WERE UNCOMFORTABLE AND HAD
DIFFICULTY CONDUCTING THE
DISSECTION.
THEY FOUND THE FORMALDEHYDE.
DIFFICULT TO STOMACH.
AND HAD STRONG VISCERAL
REACTIONS TO THE CUTTING AND
DISMEMBERING OF THE RATS.
WHICH AFFECTED THEIR ABILITY TO
FOCUS AND EFFECTIVELY COMPREHEND
THE COURSE WORK.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE PRECAUTIONARY
STEPS THAT I TOOK TO LIMIT THE
EXPOSURE TO FORMALDEHYDE.
ANY EXPOSURE TO THESE AIRBORNE
TOXINS CAN BE HARMFUL.
INSTEAD OF USING ACTUAL ANIMAL
SPECIMENS.
I WOULD HAVE PREFERRED USING
ALTERNATIVE HUMANE TEACH SCIENCE
TEACHING TOOLS SUCH AS DIGITAL.
AND VIRTUAL DISSECTION.
WHICH I BELIEVE ARE FAR SUPERIOR
TO THE OLD ANIMAL DISSECTION
PROTOCOL.
THERE ARE NO TOXIC CHEMICALS.
NO MESS NO CHANCE OF INJURY.
NO ODOR.
AND INVOLVES NO TIME FOR CLEAN
UP.
STUDENTS WOULD HAVE.
HAD THE CHANCE TO WORK ON THE
LESSON AT HOME AND REPEAT
INSTRUCTIONS IF THEY MADE A
MISTAKE.
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN OF GREAT
BENEFIT TO THEM.
STUDENTS MAY HAVE A MORBID
CURIOSITY ABOUT WHAT'S INSIDE AN
ANIMAL.
BUT I HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND THE
STUDENTS BENEFIT WHEN UP ALL
HAVE ACCESS TO THE CURRICULUM.
AS A TEACHER IT WAS MY
OBLIGATION TO TEACH RESPECT FOR
OTHERS.
WHICH INCLUDES THE HUMANE
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS.
TEACHING COMPASSIONATE SCHOOLS
LEADS TO KINDER ADULTS WHO TREAT
ALL WITH KINDNESS AND RESPECT.
THERE IS NO REASON TO DISSECT
ANIMALS WHEN WE CAN TEACH THE
NEXT GENERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE
IN OTHER WORDS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
HELLO MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SACKETT SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION THE CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL WE WE LIKE. TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL FOR
OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION AND
THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS WORK
AND CONSIDERATION OF THIS
MEASURE.
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS MODERN
SCIENCE CURRICULA AND STANDARDS
DO NOT REQUIRE -- OR REFERENCE
THE USE OF ANIMAL THEY SECTION
IN FACT THE COLLEGE BOARD'S AP
BIOLOGY THE INTERNATIONAL
BACCALAUREATE.
AND NEXT GENERATION SCIENCE
STANDARDS MAKE NO MENTION OF AN
ANIMAL THEY SECTION.
THE POPULAR UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS SECTION IS SCHOOLS IS THAT
IT IS THE DAY SECTION OF FROGS
AND WARMS.
HOWEVER A RECENT SURVEY OF
SCHOOLS THAT REQUIRED A SECTION
AS PART OF THEIR SCIENCE
CURRICULA INCLUDE FETAL PIGS.
CATS SHARKS SHEEP AND OTHER
ANIMALS.
ADVANCES IN MEDICAL SIMULATION
TECHNOLOGY AT THE EDUCATORS NEED
FOR BETTER TEACHING AND
ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND GROWING
CONCERN ABOUT ANIMAL USE IN
LABORATORY EXPERIMENTS HAVE ALL
CONTRIBUTED TO A PARADIGM SHIFT
IN BIO MEDICAL EDUCATION.
TODAY SIMULATION BASED LEARNING
IS MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE NON
ANIMAL TEACHING METHODS INCLUDES
INCLUDE INTERACTIVE COMPUTER
PROGRAMS HIGH QUALITY VIDEOS AND
LIFE LIKE MODELS.
THEY HAVE INHERENT EDUCATIONAL
ADVANTAGES FOR SCIENCE EDUCATION
SAYS IS EASE OF USE CUSTOMIZE
CUSTOMIZATION AND REPEAT
REPUTATION FOR LEARNING PURPOSES.
NON ANIMAL TEACHING METHOD SAVE
TIME CUT COSTS AND IMPROVE CITY.
STUDENT SAFETY ADDITIONALLY THIS
WOULD HELP TO REMOVE STUDENT AND
TEACHER EXPOSURE TO VARIOUS
EXPENSIVE.
CARCINOGENIC AND EVEN FATAL
CHEMICALS SUCH AS FORMALDEHYDE.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT FROM
ALL THE HEIGHT IS CLASSIFIED AS
A GROUP ONE CARCINOGEN IS LISTED
ON PROP.
SIXTY FIVE AS A CHEMICAL THAT
CAUSES CANCER AND CANNOT BE
ENTIRELY ELIMINATED THROUGH
WASHING.
IT IS IN FACT AN ANIMAL IN FACT
ANIMALS ARE COLLECTED SOURCE
FROM -- THESE ARE DALY SUMMARIZE
YES -- JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
THIS WILL ALSO HAVE A GOOD
EFFECT ON THE ENVIRONMENT BY
REDUCING THE ANIMALS PULLED FROM
THE WILD AND WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE GUY.
THANK YOU.
NOW HERE FROM OPPOSITION.
I'M SORRY OTHER I'M SORRY I'M
AND MYSELF.
THE OTHERS IN SUPPORT YOU GOT UP
TO THE MICROPHONE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY.
SO YOU SAY ANYTHING ELSE YOU'LL
BE CUT OFF AND YOU'RE TAKING
TIME AWAY FROM OTHERS IF YOU DO
SAYING ELSE JUST YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE THANK YOU.
AND ALEXIS HAVE MASTERS AS
MEDICAL SCIENCE TELLS SO SEAT
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT PLEASE
SUPPORT.
THE PASSING OF AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
SIX THINK.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE ROBERTS
I'M A CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
BIOLOGY.
TEACHER FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS.
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL.
MY NAME IS CAMILLE VANDENBERG
I'M A LOCAL SCULPTOR.
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL WITH ALL
OF MY HEART AND BEING.
MY NAME'S PETER VANDENBERG OF
BEEN AND PROFESSOR HAD JUST AS
HE IS US FOR THIRTY OVER THIRTY
YEARS.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY THANK YOU.
IN THE MIDDLE FOREST I'M HERE ON
BEHALF TO IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MEGHAN ANDERSON
MáS ANDERSON MCALLISTER EIGHT
SAN MARCOS ALONE AND I SUPPORT
AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX MY NAME'S OUR
GRASS OF IT FROM SACRAMENTO I'M
HERE WITH IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SAYS THE MAN NOT LIKE HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF ANIMAL
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND APOLOGIES WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET A LETTER IN
ON TIME BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JULIE
WORTH MAN I'M AN ATTORNEY FROM
SACRAMENTO I SUPPORT THE BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
YOU DO THE SAME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR
BETTINA CRUCIFY KEYS BY DUKE A
PHYSICIAN HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
I'M KAREN COIN TENURED TEACHER
IN THE NEWPORT MESA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT DISTRICT AN
ADVISER OF THE COMPASSION IN
ACTION CLUB AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE MODELING EMPATHY IN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NAY BENSON I'M
WITH ANONYMOUS FROM VOICELESS
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I AM THE GOD OF THE BY ON AND
I AM A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER FROM
PASADENA CALIFORNIA AND A DEBATE
COACH AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I'M KAREN SHOCKED I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I AM A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST WHO REFUSED TO DO --
ANYTHING THE HI MY NAME'S TARA
CONFIDE AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M JACQUI DAY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
TEACHER OF THE YEAR AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
POLY PACKARD A RETIRED TEACHER
LIVING IN WEST SACRAMENTO I
SUPPORT YOUR BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARSHALL LOWRY I'M
WITH PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE AND IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMAL.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ZERO SLAWSON OF A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JAMES WHO AND
I'M A RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL COMPLETELY.
GIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LEADER LAFIA
I'M FROM TRUCKEE CALIFORNIA AND
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
SUSAN KIRKPATRICK FROM TURKEY
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY MARKET KIRKPATRICK FROM
TURKEY CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER BUTLER
FROM LONG BEACH AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES FOR THIS
BILL.
BECAUSE MY GENERATION NEEDS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TO NOW PLUS YOUR
MOTHER EDUCATOR AND I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIE MCCARTY I'M A
STUDENT TO TRY TO MIDDLE SCHOOL
SCIENCE CLASSROOM AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARTA HOMBURG AND I'M
A RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND AS A PARENT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TERRY LEASE I FROM
OUT THE CALIFORNIAN I SUPPORT
THE BILL.
I'M GENOMIC BRIDE FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA WITH CONNECTION EARTH WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
I AM MANDATE WHEELER AND I AM
THE FOUNDER OF CONNECTION EARTH
LAND THERE AND SEE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS RUTH RIVERA I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
JENNIFER IS SCHOOL OF CINEMA
COUNTY CALIFORNIA HERE ON BEHALF
OF PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KATHY GARCIA SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA REGISTERED NURSE AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HOUSE LEE LEWIS FROM FAIRFAX
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF PETER
AND ARE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DONE WHAT NAME I'M AN ATTORNEY
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA KEVIN
MCCARTY STE IS TAKEN ANY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE ADVICE FROM
OUR PER CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS GABBY SOTO I'M
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HELLO WENDY BRAMBLE FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HELLO I'M JANE VELEZ MITCHELL
I'M A JOURNALIST AND AUTHOR I
LIVE IN MARINA DEL REY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL WILL TEACH
KINDNESS NOT CRUELTY.
HI JUDY MAN CREW SO FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL COMPASSION
AND LEGISLATION.
SPONSORED THE BILL AND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NO LONGER FAR --
I AM A MOLECULAR BIOLOGIST AND
FOUNDER OF CULTIVATE EMPATHY FOR
ALL AND I TOTALLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- NOW WE'LL TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION AND THE
OPPOSITION WOULD COME FORWARD.
IF WE CAN MAKE ROOM FOR THEM
PLEASE THANK YOU
.
I'M SECTIONS OF THE SERVERS
[inaudible] SEVEN GREAT.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY WITH
THE OPPOSITION.
WHAT'S PRESS THE BUTTON OKAY
GOOD MORE A GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS PETER VAN METER I'M AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR HIGH SCHOOL
BIOLOGY ANATOMY PHYSIOLOGY.
AND MARINE BIOLOGY TEACHER FROM
AM OKAY HIGH SCHOOL IN RIVERSIDE
UST.
IN A CHAIR OF THE CTA'S
CURRICULUM INSTRUCTIONS
COMMITTEE.
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I'M URGING
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX BANNING DIE
SECTIONS AND CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
CTA BELIEVES THE BILL IS
UNNECESSARY GIVEN THE CURRENT
STATE OP -- STATE OPT OUT OF LAW
FOR STUDENTS WITH NORMAL OBJECT
A MORAL OBJECTIONS TO
PARTICIPATING SIGN SLAPS CTA MET
WITH THE AUTHOR AND DISCUSS
POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS WITHOUT
AGREEMENT.
CITY STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL
BECAUSE OF IT ELIMINATES
EDUCATIONS PROFESSIONALS
EXPERTISE TO STAY SECTION AS A
MEANINGFUL LEARNING EXPERIENCE
PROMOTING HIGH SCHOOL SCIENCE
UNSURPASSED.
BY ANY OTHER INSTRUCTIONAL TOOL
TO STUDENTS INTERESTED IN AND
BEEN BENEFITING FROM THIS HANDS
ON LEARNING METHOD.
IT IMPOSES NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
ON TEACHERS AND STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS WILL FEEL
NEGLIGENT IN THEIR DUTY TO MEET
THE LEARNING NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS WILL FEEL
DEPRIVED OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHOOSE.
MEANINGFUL AND EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES OF SCIENCE LEARNING
THROUGH DISSECTION.
TAKE A LET ME STUDENTS TAKING
HONORS ADVANCED PLACEMENT
CLASSES AND COLLEGE ARTICULATED
COURSES REQUIRING DISSECTION.
THEY SECTIONS VALUE IN
CALIFORNIA NEXT GENERATION
SCIENCE STANDARDS IS ILLUSTRATED
IN A THREE DIMENSIONAL APPROACH
TO SCIENCE EDUCATION GRAPHIC AND
NARRATIVE OF CORE IDEAS
PRACTICES AND CROSS CUTTING
CONCEPTS ON PAGE.
FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
THE BILLS PROHIBITS XIN ON
TEACHERS USING STANDARDS ALIGNED
INSTRUCTIONAL TOOLS ON NICE
SECTION TO BENEFIT STUDENT
LEARNING UNDERMINES MEETING THAT
CALIFORNIA DASHBOARD
REQUIREMENTS ON COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS.
CDA ASKED THE COMMITTEE TO TRUST
TEACHERS PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE
AND TRUST STUDENTS TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES TO OPT OUT OF SCIENCE
LABS.
CTA APPRECIATES THE AUTHORS
POLICY BRIEFING ON ALTERNATIVES
TO DIE SECTION AND IS OPEN TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TO
IMPROVE STATE OPT OUT LAW FOR
STUDENTS.
BUT WE RESPECTFULLY URGE I KNOW
VOTE TO BAN ANIMAL DISSECTION IN
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE INSTRUCTION
FOR THE REASONS STATED I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY
NAME IS A LESSON IMAGE COUPLE
FAIRFIELD AND I AM.
HERE ON BEHALF OF C. S. T. A AND
AN ELEMENTARY CLASSROOM SCIENCE
TEACHER.
I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU TO
PLEAD WITH YOU TO PLEASE NOT
TAKE AWAY FROM THE EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE I HAVE DESIGNED FOR
MY STUDENTS.
AND NOT TO TAKE AWAY.
FROM THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
IN MEANINGFUL AND EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES THAT INCLUDE ANIMAL
DISSECTION THEY SECTION AS A
TOOL TO HELP ENGAGE STUDENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA NEXT GENERATION
SCIENCE STANDARDS HAVE SHIFTED
INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICES TO
SUPPORTING SCIENTIFIC IT
SCIENTIFICALLY LITERATE SOCIETY
WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS THAT WILL IMPACT
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
A MAJOR COMPONENT OF THE SHIFT
IS THAT STUDENTS ARE DRIVING THE
INSTRUCTION.
IN USING THE SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERING PRACTICES AND CROSS
CUTTING CONCEPTS MY STUDENTS ARE
THE ONES ATTEMPTING TO EXPLAIN
PHENOMENA BY ASKING THE
QUESTIONS ARE YOU GOING FROM
EVIDENCE AND ATTEMPTING TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS.
IN A HANDS ON MATTER THAT IS
DESIGNED BY STUDENTS NATURAL
CURIOSITY AND WONDER.
THE DIGITAL TOOLS DO NOT SUPPORT
THIS TYPE OF INSTRUCTION AND
REMOVE THE COLLABORATIVE ASPECT
OF THE SCIENCE CLASSROOM.
STUDENTS CURIOSITY IN WONDER ARE
NOT DRIVING INSTRUCTION INSTEAD
STUDENTS ARE SHOWN ONE PERSON'S
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT IS
INTERESTING ABOUT A SINGULAR
SPECIMEN.
THE PRACTICE IS THE ANTITHESIS
OF THE NATURE OF SCIENCE THE
FOUNDATION FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS.
IN THAT SCIENTISTS OBSERVE
MULTIPLE SPECIMENS FOR VARIATION
OF TRAITS.
AS A TEACHER IT IS MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO DETERMINE WHAT
IS APPROPRIATE FOR MY CLASSROOM.
IN MAKING THESE DECISIONS I
CONSIDER THE CULTURAL AND SOCIAL
I CARE ABOUT MY STUDENTS AND
WANT WHAT IS BEST FOR THEM.
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO OPT OUT OF
ALL CLASS INVESTIGATIONS
INVOLVING SPECIMENS TO THE LEVEL
OF THEIR COMFORT.
I MAKE THIS WELL KNOWN IN MY
CLASSROOM AND AT MY SITE.
IT IS NOT A REQUIREMENT FOR ALL
GRADES OR EVEN CLASSROOMS WITH
ANY GRADE LEVEL AND IS TEACHER
CHOICE WHETHER OR NOT TO PERFORM
A DISSECTION ACTIVITY.
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER I PROVIDE
EXPLICIT INSTRUCTION ON THE
ETHICAL TREATMENT OF ALL
SPECIMENS IN THE CLASSROOM AND
IN THE HOME.
THIS HAS ACTUALLY RESULTED IN
HEIGHTENED AWARENESS AND
COMPASSION FOR ANIMALS THAT
STUDENTS WOULD NOT TYPICALLY
CONSIDER WORTHY.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I NEED THE
APPROPRIATE DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS BEST FOR
STUDENTS SUCH AS THE HIGH
ENGLISH LEARNER ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNER POPULATION WHO DO NOT
BENEFIT FROM WORKSHEETS SUCH AS
THOSE OFFERED BY THE DIGITAL
PROGRAMS.
BUT NEED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD AND MAKE SENSE OF THEIR
CONCEPTUAL FRAMEWORKS I AM
ASKING YOU TO LEAVE THIS
DECISION IN THE HANDS OF
TEACHERS THAT CARE ABOUT THE
WELL BEING OF THEIR STUDENTS NOT
ONLY WHILE THEY'RE IN OUR
pBUT ALSO THE ADULTS THEY WILL
BECOME THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY MAKE
PRIDE IN BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS UNFORTUNATELY
ACCESS IS ALSO OPPOSED TO A. B.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX WE THINK IT
JUST GOES TOO FAR BY PROHIBITING
STUDENTS FROM PERFORMING DIE
SECTIONS.
IN A CALIFORNIA PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE SCHOOL THEY SECTION IS
ALREADY AN OPTIONAL CLASSROOM
ACTIVITY IN SOME SCHOOLS I
SECTION IS A VALUABLE TEACHING
TOOL AND IT OTHER STUDENTS MAY
HAVE ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY OR A
COMBINATION OF BOTH.
BUT THEY HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
LOCALLY TO DECIDE AGAIN THIS IS
OPTIONAL AND SHOULD CONTINUE TO
BE.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX IS COUNTER
TO LOCAL CONTROL AND WOULD
REMOVE HANDS ON LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AND EDUCATIONAL
CHOICES FROM CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THIS BAND IS TOO AGGRESSIVE AND
SUGGEST THAT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
LEADERS TEACHERS AND STUDENTS
ARE DOING SOMETHING EXPLICITLY
WRONG THAT WARRANT STATE
INTERVENTION WE DON'T BELIEVE
THIS IS THE CASE.
WE SHOULD BE EXPANDING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ENGAGE STUDENTS AND FOSTER
COLLABORATIVE TACTILE CLASSROOM
EXPERIENCES WE SHOULD BE ADDING
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO THE
TOOLBOX NOT TAKING THEM AWAY.
IN ADDITION TO THAT SECTION
BEING ALREADY BEING OPTIONAL
STUDENTS THEMSELVES HAVE THE
RIGHT TO OPT OUT OF
PARTICIPATING IN CLASSROOM BY
SECTIONS.
THE OPT OUT SECTION A IF THE OPT
OUT SESSION OF THE EDUCATION
CODE IS NO LONGER SUFFICIENT OR
NEEDS CLARIFICATION.
AN AXE IS HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
THAT POLICY DISCUSSION.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON PAGE
TWELVE SUGGESTS AN INTERESTING
ALTERNATIVE TO AN OUTRIGHT BAN
AND THAT ARE INTERESTING
PROPOSALS.
WHICH AGAIN WE ARE HAPPY TO
DISCUSS WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR PLEASE RISE.
WE MUST OPPOSE IN OUR BAND AYE
DISSECTION.
WHICH IS THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE TO COME.
SAID OF THE PROBLEM THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO SOLVE AND WHETHER THIS
BAND IS ACTUALLY THE APPROPRIATE
STATEWIDE POLICY SOLUTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
AS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALL OF ROCK
RIGHT CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS TAYLOR RUSH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND
THE ONLY HALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA EGG FARMERS.
GRAIN AND FEED ASSOCIATION PORK
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION WALKER
CESSATION OF PACIFIC IN EXAMPLE
TRAIN OPPOSITION.
MATT PATTON CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND EIGHTEEN YEAR
AGRICULTURAL BIOLOGY TEACHER IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION SING
OPPOSITE FOR THEIR OPPOSITION
WE'RE BEHIND.
THE REAL TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS MANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THE FIRST.
SEVERAL QUESTIONS THE FIRST OFF
THAT I HAD A GATE MISTER KALRA.
YOU MENTIONED THAT -- WITH THIS
BILL THERE WOULD NOT BE A
PROHIBITION ON DIE SECTIONS
YOU'RE YOU'RE ALLUDING THAT.
THE STUDENTS WOULDN'T BE
DISSECTING BUT THAT THE TEACHERS
WOULD STILL BE.
THAT THEY HAVE THAT RIGHT AS ACT.
CAN YOU HELP US KNOW THROUGH THE
CHAIR -- NOTE THAT THAT IT WOULD
BE AN ANIMAL DISSECTION --
DISSECTION BY ITSELF DOESN'T
REQUIRE THAT HAVE TO BE AN
ANIMAL AFTER DISSECTING.
THE WHAT THAT SECTION WITH THE
COULD BE A MODEL COULD BE THE
COULD BE THROUGH TECHNOLOGY
COULD BE THREE TIMES A THREE
DIMENSIONAL IT COULD BE.
ANY NUMBER IT AT THE
DEMONSTRATION THURSDAY THERE
ALSO OTHER PHYSICAL -- TYPES OF
OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF MODELING
OF YEAH FROGS AND OTHER THINGS
THAT CAN BE DIE SO YEAH.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IS
THAT THE PUSH FOR THIS IS TWO
FOLD IT AND I UNDERSTAND --
STAND WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM
AND I AM.
I'M NOT I'M NOT CONVINCED ON
THIS AND SO I HAVE SOME SOME
QUESTIONS I WANTED TO ALLOW YOU
TO PROTECT POTENTIALLY PERSUADE
ME.
SO.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IS TWO FOLD
IS THAT ONE DAY EXISTING LAW
WHICH I GUESS WAS THAT.
JACKIE SPEARED MEASURE FROM TWO
DECADES AGO WHICH ALLOW STUDENTS
TO OPT OUT.
IS -- IS INSUFFICIENT AND
DOESN'T HAVE -- THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE STUDENTS TO HAVE.
A MEANINGFUL SCIENCE
PARTICIPATION SO THAT'S ONE PART
OF IT AND THE OTHER PART OF YOUR
ARGUMENT I I THINK THE LARGER
ARGUMENT YOU THINK THIS IS --
IMMORAL AND AND NOT NECESSARY IN
TODAY'S DAY AND AGE WITH THAT
TECHNOLOGY WELL YEAH CERTAINLY
MORALITY BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF
HOW INSTRUCTIONS BEING DONE I
MEAN.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO MEDICAL
SCHOOL.
THE BACHELOR'S A MEDICAL TO
PROVE THAT THEY'RE NOT
DISSECTING ANIMALS ARE USING
TECHNOLOGY.
I MEAN IF YOU REALLY WANT TO
TRAIN DOES THAT MAKE CHOOSE A
CAREER OF THE SCIENCES YOU
TRAINED ON WITH WHAT.
AND EVENTUALLY WILL HAVE A
CHANCE.
TO YOU KNOW THAT I SECOND HOURS
BUT OF THE POINT IS THAT.
WE WANT TO FIRST OF ALL BEING
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD OFFER WHAT
I BELIEVED TO BE THE BEST AND
NOT JUST ME THAT LOOK LIKE AS I
MENTIONED IS THIRTY FIVE PLUS
STUDIES.
THAT SHOW IT'S COMPARABLE OR
BETTER TO USE ALTERNATE METHODS
THAT ANIMAL DISSECTION AND I
JUST I SECTION IS ONE ACT SURE --
BUT ISN'T IT CHOICE IN THAT SO
IT'S NOT MEDICAL SCHOOL THE
STUDENTS ARE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ABOUT INSPIRING THEM TO
MAYBE GOING TO STEM EDUCATION SO.
YOU KNOW MAYBE THE PHYSICAL ACT --
THINGY ANIMAL INSPIRE SOMEONE IN
SCIENCE AND AND WHAT'S WHAT'S
WHAT'S WRONG WITH HAVING THAT
OPTION FOR SOON TO DO THAT OR
CONVERSELY OPT OUT LIKE THE
OTHER STUDENTS SAID THAT SHE
DIDN'T HAVE THE I WOULD VENTURE
TO SAY IN FACT JUST BY CHANCE.
ABOUT AN HOUR AGO -- IS STAFFERS
MENTION BECAUSE THE CONVERSATION
CAME UP THIS WAS CONCERNING
MEDICAL SCHOOL SOCIAL AND TOUCH
IT I SECTION.
THIS CONSIDER THOSE THAT ARE
BEING PUSHED AWAY AT A YOUNG AGE
AND THEY'RE NOT PREPARED FOR
THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY TO NEVER
GO TO MEDICAL SCHOOL I THINK
THAT'S A FAR MORE.
COMMON OCCURRENCE OF SOMEONE
THAT SPARKED BUT EVENTUALLY GOES
INTO THE SCIENCES THE THE
TECHNOLOGY THE OTHER ALL TERMS
AVAILABLE ALSO SPARK.
GREAT INTEREST IN GREAT DESIRE
AND I HAD THE GREAT OPPORTUNITY
IS YOUR DAUGHTER REALLY ENJOYING
SOME OF THEM ON THURSDAY AT THE
BRIEFING AND WAS REALLY COOL TO
SEE.
BECAUSE OF THIS IS THE KIND OF
LEARNING THAT MORE MORE THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE A CUSTOM --
TO MANY EVEN LIFE SCIENCES
COMPANIES AND OTHER COMPANIES --
THEY'RE DOING RESEARCH ARE NOT
USING ANIMALS -- THEY'RE MOVING
MORE MORE AWAY FROM.
AND SO THE REALITY IS THAT IF WE
REALLY WANT TO SPARK INTEREST
DESPITE THE INTERESTS I DON'T
THINK YOU SUBJECT A 100% OF
STUDENTS. TO THIS ACT OF CUTTING
INDIANA AND ANIMALS TO SPARK
INTEREST THIRD.
STRAIGHT SHOOTER BECAUSE
WOULDN'T BE 100% IF IT'S AN
OPTION AND IN YOU YOU ALLUDED --
TO YES THE LAST NEARLY TWO WEEKS --
ONE OF MY TWIN DAUGHTERS HAD THE
CHANCE TO STUMBLE ACROSS YOUR
EXHIBITOR DAY AND MESS AROUND
THE IPAD -- TO GREAT SKILL MY
UNDERSTANDING AND THE OTHER --
DAUGHTER A FEW WEEKS AGO WAS
ABLE TO HELP BE PART OF A
DISSECTION OF A PIG AND TAKES
HEART IN THEIR CLASSROOM.
AND HE TALKED ABOUT HOW THAT WAS
INTRIGUING AND INTERESTING IN A
LONG TIME THAT TOO SO I DO SEE
THE VALUE OF A BOTH OF THESE --
UP THE PIECES AND SO -- WE KNOW
YOUR BILL DO YOU WOULDN'T HOW
ALLOW ANY OF THAT -- TO TO BE
ABLE TO TO OCCUR.
AND THEN WHAT ABOUT THE YOU KNOW
THAT TECHNOLOGY AND COST I'M
SURE THERE'S A PREFERRED VENDOR
WHOSE YOU KNOW CHOMPING AT THE
BIT RATE AND MAKE MONEY SELLING
THIS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND YOU
KNOW THAT'S A FACTOR AS WELL AND
SO WOULD WOULD WE BE ABLE. TO TO
YOU KNOW. TO THIS RIGHT AWAY I
I'D KNOW THERE'S SOME CONCERTS
FROM THAT SCHOOL COMMUNITY
BEHIND YOU BOTH THE TEACHERS AND
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS COURSE TO
YOUR RIGHT.
WELL I WOULD I WAS FIRST OF ALL
BE WILLING TO HAVE A TIME PERIOD.
FOR THIS TO GOING TO A FACT
WOULDN'T BE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR SO
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO GET PREPARED FOR IT
SECONDLY YOU'RE PRESUMING RIGHT
NOW THAT AREN'T VENDORS RIGHT
NOW MAKING A WHOLE BUNCH OF
MONEY.
OFF SELLING THESE ANIMALS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR AS OPPOSED TO THE
COST -- THE START UP COSTS --
WHICH ARE OFTENTIMES AT THE SAME
WAY CHEAPER THAN BUYING ANIMALS
FOR ONE YEAR.
AND SO.
BE IT I DON'T MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON WHAT ONE VENDOR IS
GONNA MAKE MONEY WONDERS ARE
THERE ARE DOZENS OF VENDORS THAT
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES DISSECTION --
AND SO IF WE'RE GOING TO ASK
THAT QUESTION YET THAT THING
SOME ONLY ASK THE QUESTION WHO'S
MAKING THE MONEY NOW TO SOMEONE
MAKING A WHOLE BUNCH OF MONEY
NOW THAT'S PROVIDING THEM.
ARE THERE JEFF RESEARCHER SAYS
ONCE MORE EXPENSIVE THE OTHER
JUST MAYBE IT'S A WASH -- I
THINK THAT IT DEPENDS ON WHAT
KIND OF TECHNOLOGY USE I THINK
THAT IT'S A WASHER CHEAPER I
THINK THAT THE ALTERNATIVE TEND
TO BE CHEAPER BUT THEN IT WILL
BE UP TO THE SCHOOL AS WELL AND
AGAIN.
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOFTWARE IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
MODELS AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE
THAT CAN BE RE USED WAS A ONE
TIME COST YOU HAVE TO REPURCHASE
ANIMALS EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
THAT'S AN ONGOING YEAR OVER YEAR
OVER YEAR COST.
OKAY AND I APOLOGIZE IF I MISS
THIS AND THEN ALSO SOMEWHERE IS
THERE IS THIS BUT THIS WOULD BE
IT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE THE
FIRST.
STATE TO DO THIS THAT'S CORRECT.
ALRIGHT THAT'S IT IF I IF I
COULD TO THE CHAIR THE THE THE
COMMENT REGARDING WALL IT GIVES
IT.
THANK EXPERIENCE THAT IS TO MY
HOUSE YES STUDENTS MIGHT HAVE A
VARIETY OF EXPERIENCES WITH
ANIMAL DISSECTION SOME AND MAYBE
MORE POSITIVE SOME MORE NEGATIVE.
PRESS MY CONTENTION THAT THE
ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE WILL GIVE
100% OF THE STUDENTS A POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE AND THE EVEN OF ONE
OFFS OUT OFTENTIMES OPT OUT
THERE ARE STILL SIT IN THE
CLASSROOM.
THEY'RE NOT GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY
OF ANYTHING NEARLY NEAR THE
EQUIVALENT OF THAT TYPE OF
INSTRUCTION.
AND IF IT'S TRULY EACH IF IT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THE ANIMAL
DEATHS AYE SECTIONS OF
UNSURPASSED BY ANY OF THE ANY OF
THE LEARNING TOOL THE ARGUMENT
SHOULD BE THAT.
IT SHOULD BE MANDATED FOR EVERY
TEACHER DO IT BUT IT'S NOT IN
FACT IT'S NOT EVEN PART OF THE
SITE IN A REQUIREMENT EDUCATION
CODE OR FOR INTERNATIONAL
BACHELOR PROGRAMS.
NEXT GENERATION SCIENCE
STANDARDS COLLEGE BOARD IT IS
TRULY UNSURPASSED THAT WOULD BE
THE CASE BUT IT'S NOT THEIR
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE JUST AS AS
GOOD IF NOT BETTER.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IF WE HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN TWO THE TWO
OPPORTUNITIES AND SOMEONE CAN
MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT OKAY WELL
EITHER ONE WILL WORK AND LET.
SOMEONE DECIDE I'M GONNA CHOOSE
FOR THE ONE THAT FIRST OF ALL
PUSHED PREPARES OUR STUDENTS FOR
THE MODERN WORLD AND HOW THEY'RE
ACTUALLY TRAIN IN THE SCIENCES
I'M ALSO GOING TO CHOOSE THE ONE
THAT DOESN'T PUT.
STUDENTS THROUGH A REALLY
HORRIFYING EXPERIENCE FOR MANY
OF THEM.
YEAH.
THANK YOU AND THEN MISTER CHAIR
OUT LAST QUESTION IF IF WE COULD
ALLOW I THINK THE THE OPPOSITION --
OUTLINED IT THERE IS A COUNTER
PROPOSAL THAT YOU WANTED.
TO THE PROS PROPOSED TO THE
AUTHOR THAT WASN'T AGREED UPON.
THAT DOES THAT RELATE TO THE TO
THE OPT OUT INTO THE OPT OUT
YEAH CAN YOU ENLIGHTEN US ABOUT
THAT.
WELL WE CAN GO IN AND ACTUALLY
LOOK AT HOW -- HOW DISTRICTS IN
HOW DO YOU PROPOSE ON PUTTING
THE INFORMATION IN FULL RIGHT SO
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE --
BECAUSE OF FOR ME AND OUR
DISTRICT -- AS HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER WE HAVE TO PUT THE
INFORMATION ON THE SYLLABUS THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING AND SO THIS
STUDENTS KNOW WAY IN ADVANCE
SPECIFICALLY ON CLASSES THAT
THEY WOULD NEED TO DO DIE
SECTION BECAUSE IT IS.
A COLLEGE ARTICULATED CLASSES
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL SO
WE HAVE TO TELL THEM IN ADVANCE
WHAT IS GOING ON THE OTHER THING
THAT WE DO IN THE CLASSROOM.
IS THAT WE DON'T START WAIT -- A
CAT OR A LARGER ANIMAL WHAT WE
DO IS WE ACTUALLY START WITH A
BANANA. TO DEEPER LOOK AT
DISSECTION NOT WAY WOULD
POSITIONS AND AFTER THAT WE KIND
OF MOVE UP.
IN.
I LOOK AT MY SCHOLARSHIP AND I
LOOK AT MY STUDENTS AND I GROUP
ON A CERTAIN WAY AND IF I FEEL
LIKE THEY DO NOT.
FEEL -- THAT THEY WANTED TO DO
THAT THEY CAN DO A ROTATION.
AND THE OTHER PARTIES IF THEY
OPT OUT.
THEN I GO IN AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
ASSIGNMENTS -- I ALWAYS DOUBLE
VIRTUAL LAP BEFORE HIM BECAUSE
THEY NEED TO FAMILIARIZE
THEMSELVES BECAUSE WHEN WE DO
THE ACTUAL DISSECTION THAT'S
WHEN WE GO IN MORE AT DEEPER
LEARNING AND CRITICAL THINKING
ANALYSIS AND THAT YOU CANNOT DO.
WHEN YOU'RE USING A A VIRTUAL
LAP OR A VIDEO?
BECAUSE IF EACH STUDENT IN MY
CLASS HAVE A GROUPS.
EACH STUDENT WITH A A HEART THAT
THEY'RE DISSECTING COULD BE A
VARIATION OF DIFFERENT SO WE CAN
ASK THE QUESTION WHY IS THAT.
WHY IS THERE A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ONE HEART TO ONE ANOTHER
IN DARKNESS PARKS TO INFLUENCE
YOU KNOW THINKING LIKE WOW WHY
IS THAT?
IN SO IT GIVES SOME MORE
INFORMATION AND TRY TO KIND OF
COOL -- INCORPORATE OTHER POOR
IDEAS THAT'S PART OF THE NEXT
GENOCIDE STANDARDS AND THAT'S
VARIATION IN TRAITS.
THANK YOU.
THE THANK YOU MISTER VERY
[inaudible]
THE DRUG -- THERE WAS A COMMENT
YOU MADE ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THIS IS NOT REQUIRED -- AS A
PART OF THE STATE STANDARDS THIS
SECTION IS NOT IS THAT AND WHAT
AS SUCH IS NOT SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRED THAT IS CORRECT OKAY
AND SO.
THE OPPOSITION IS ALLEGING THAT
IT IS IS THAT CORRECT NO I DON'T
BELIEVE.
THAT ANYONE SAID.
IT'S NOT THAT IT IS REQUIRED BUT
BY THE NATURE OF THE SHIP'S
DEMANDED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NEXT GENERATION SCIENCES IT
LENDS ITSELF TO THAT TYPE OF
ACTIVITY OF FIVE MAY GIVE AN
EXAMPLE IN MY FOURTH GRADE
CLASSROOM.
WE STUDY STRUCTURE AND FUNCTION
OF ANIMALS AND I HAVE A SECTION
COMING UP WHEN I GO BACK TO TO
SCHOOL.
NEXT WEEK WHERE WE WILL BE
DISSECTING CHICKEN Vì AND
CHICKEN WINGS AND MY STUDENTS
THEN USE WHAT THEY LEARN ABOUT
THE STRUCTURE AND FUNCTION OF
THE TENDONS OF THE BONES.
AND LIGAMENTS IN THE CHICKEN
FEET AND WINGS TO THEN DESIGN A
BIO AND THE BIONIC HAND THAT
THEY USE SO THEY'RE TAKING THAT
KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY LEARN TO
THAT I SECTION AND APPLYING IT
IN AN ENGINEERING PROCESS AND
NOT PART OF THE SHIPS.
AND THIS IS IN WHAT WHAT GREAT
FOR THAT RIGHT FOURTH GRADE OKAY
OKAY -- IS -- MY CONCERN.
IF THERE IS A CONCERN AYE AYE I
LIKE TO SECTION WHEN I WAS IN
SCHOOL SO MAYBE THAT LITTLE GORY
ABOUT THAT BUT I DID LIKE IT BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT HAS TO BE
THERE TODAY THAT'S A LONG TIME
AGO -- MY CONCERN IS IS IS MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAT.
I DON'T SEE DISSECTION OCCURRING
IN EVERY SCHOOL.
AND THAT'S MY REAL CONCERN NOT
SO MUCH EVEN THAT SAY SECTION I
DON'T SEE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
THAT IS -- HANDS ON THAT
INSPIRES AND MOTIVATES
PARTICULARLY IN THE SCHOOLS OF
THE THE LOWER SOCIOECONOMIC
LEVEL AND SO THAT MY CONCERN IS
IS THERE'S NOT ENOUGH OF THAT.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS WOULD
MAKE MORE OF IT AVAILABLE I'M
NOT REALLY SURE BUT I KNOW THAT
HAVING WORK WITH A WHOLE BUNCH
OF SCIENCE EXT PROGRAMS THAT
EXTERNAL TO SCHOOLS.
WITH HIS AT THE UNIVERSITY OR
WHETHER IN ONE OF OUR INSTITUTES
IN THE COMMUNITY.
THAT THAT IS WHAT SPARKED THE
INTEREST OF INNER CITY KIDS THE
FACT THAT THIS IS SCIENCE ITS
HANDS ON THEY CAN SEE IT --
WHETHER IT'S IN A VIDEO OR
WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW -- WHETHER
IT'S VIRTUAL -- THAT'S MY MAIN
CONCERN AND MAYBE VIRTUAL MAKE
IT MORE ACCESSIBLE -- THAT'S MY
ANOTHER ISSUE ARE REYES I'M NOT
SURE -- BECAUSE MAYBE THAT THE
INSTRUCTORS HAVE SOME
DIFFICULTIES THEMSELVES DEALING
WITH THAT BUT I DO KNOW THAT IT
IS THE THING THAT REALLY TURNS
KIDS ON TO SCIENCE.
AND TOO OFTEN OUR KIDS IT TURNED
OFF BY CHALKING TALK WHICH IS.
WHAT WE DO A LOT OF SO I AM NOT
SURE IF THIS WILL HELP IT MAYBE
IT WILL -- I LIKE MORE
INFORMATION I MAY GIVE YOU I'LL
GIVE YOU MY SUPPORT FOR THE DAY
BUT I'M REALLY MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT I WANT.
HANDS ON SCIENCE.
IN ALL CLASSROOMS BECAUSE
WITHOUT IT I THINK OUR STUDENTS
DO NOT GET THE BENEFIT OF BEING
INSPIRED AND IT AND AND ABLE TO
ASK THOSE CRITICAL QUESTIONS
THAT YOU SAY YOUR STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO ASK.
IN A CLASSROOM AND AND WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH OF THOSE HANDS ON
EXPERIENCES THAT REALLY TURN
KIDS ON A TO SCIENCE THEY'RE
VERY TURNED OFF UNFORTUNATELY IN
SCIENCE IS A VERY EXCITING FIELD.
I AGREE WITH YOU DODD WEBER AND
I THINK THE ALTERNATIVE THE
TECHNOLOGICAL TURN LIVES
INCLUDING HANDS ON ALTERNATIVES
TO PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE THE
INTERACTIVE ACTIVITY I ALSO
AGREE WITH APPLY MANY SCHOOLS I
DON'T DISSECT AND IF IT IS THE
UNSURPASSED LEARNING TOOL --
THEN CLEARLY THE THEIR SCHOOLS
ARE GETTING BY TEACHING WITHOUT
DOING IT AND THERE ARE SOME
SCHOOLS THAT USE TECHNOLOGY --
MEDICAL SCHOOLS -- CERTAINLY
PROVIDE CRITICAL ANALYSIS USING
TECHNOLOGICAL TOOLS THAT ARE FAR
SURPASS THAT THAT THAT THAT --
SURPASS ANIMAL DISSECTION
BECAUSE THEY DON'T DO ANIMAL
SECTION -- AND YEAH AND SO THE
SUGGESTION THAT THERE'S ONLY ONE
WAY TO SPARK THAT CRITICAL
ANALYSIS JUST FALLS THERE'S
PLENTY OF HANDS ON OPPORTUNITIES
TECHNOLOGICAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
SPARK OF THAT INTEREST AND I
AGREE THAT WE HAVE TO BRING THAT
KIND OF TECHNOLOGY TO ALL OUR
SCHOOLS.
AND WE HAVE TO BRING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ALL OUR SCHOOLS --
IN SO I THINK THAT THE THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY CERTAINLY TO DO THAT --
WITH THIS BILL -- BECAUSE I I
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY IN THE LONG
TERM IT IS A COST SAVINGS TO
SCHOOLS THAT OTHERWISE HAVE TO
EVERY YEAR PURCHASE ANIMALS AND
AGAIN.
AS WE DISCUSSED -- PREVIOUSLY IF
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
DISTRICTS NUMBER ANIMALS AT
THEIR PURCHASING THEY'RE CLEARLY
NOT PROVIDING THIS.
EDUCATIONAL AND I'M I'M VERY
HAPPY THAT WE HAVE TEACHERS THAT
ARE UP OF COMFORTABLE PROMOTE
THE PRESENTING AND AND PROVIDING.
OF A CURRICULUM AND IT IS A
LESSON PLAN THAT THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT THEY THAT
THEY BELIEVE THE STUDENTS ENJOY
BUT ULTIMATELY EVEN WITH IT AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED BY.
SOME MCCARTY -- BUT WITH THE OPT
OUT WHAT HAVE YOU LET'S THINK
ABOUT THE REALITY OF OF
TEENAGERS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL OR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CHILDREN.
BEING ASKED BY THEIR A THORNY
FIGURE WHETHER THEY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOMETHING OPT OUT.
A BOMB IN MIDDLE SCHOOL WHERE I
DID HAVE TO DO A DISSECTION I
DIDN'T WANT.
TO BUT I DID IT.
BECAUSE WELL WHAT AM I GONNA DO
ON ON A TWO YOUNG TEENAGE BOY
GOING TO GO OUT IN THE
PLAYGROUND AT RECESS.
AND HAVE THE KIDS MAKE FUN
EXCITED ONE OPT OUT TO BE A TO
BE REALLY.
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT ABOUT THE
CHILDREN AND THE IMPACT THAT IT
HAS TO ACTUALLY PERFORM ANIMAL
DISSECTION EVEN IF IT SPARKS
INTEREST AND SOME.
EVEN BUT TO PUT UP OR WHATEVER
TO ACQUIRE A 100% TO DO IT OR TO
SEPARATE THEMSELVES AND REST THE
CLASS I THINK IS A PRETTY -- BUT
IT'S AS A LOT TO ASK OF OUR
STUDENTS -- AND I JUST WANT TO
ADD ONE MORE POINT I DID MAKE IT
EARLIER THAT THERE IS AN
EXEMPTION FOR SPECIALIZED ACT
CLASSES -- BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT I'VE CULTURE COMMUNITY
THIRDS ARE UNIQUE FEELS THAT IT
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITIES THAT
LEND THEMSELVES TO GOING
VETERINARY GOING INTO OBVIOUSLY
RAISING LIVESTOCK WHAT HAVE YOU
SO THERE IS AN EXEMPTION FOR
SPECIALIZED HAD CLASSES.
THANK YOU -- LET ME LET ME MAKE
A FEW COMMENTS ON THIS -- YEAH
I'M AN ANIMAL LOVER I'VE TO
RESCUE DOGS AT HOME I'VE WORKED
WITH SOCIAL COMPASSIONATE
LEGISLATION -- AND WE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT BILL JUST A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THAT WE GOT THROUGH
THAT WE DIDN'T THINK WE'RE GONNA
GET THROUGH WE DID NOW I THINK
IT'S THE NATIONAL MODEL -- BUT
WHERE I FALL ON THIS IS.
THIS ABSOLUTELY REMOVES LOCAL
CONTROL.
THIS ABSOLUTELY WILL COST MORE
MONEY.
THESE CLASSROOMS DO NOT HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TODAY AND IN FACT IF
YOU BUY SOFTWARE YOU CAN
DOWNLOAD IT YOUR CHROMEBOOK
RIGHT IT'S GOT TO BE ONLINE.
SO AGAIN -- THIS IS COMING FROM
A TEACHER SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN IN
THE CLASSROOM FOR MANY YEARS --
WE SHOULDN'T BE DESIGNING LESSON
PLANS FROM SACRAMENTO.
WE SHOULD ALLOW TEACHERS TO HAVE
THE AUTONOMY SO THEY CAN BEST
MEET THE NEEDS.
OF THEIR STUDENTS SO LET ME GO
THROUGH A COUPLE OTHER THINGS
AGAIN INCREASED COSTS OF HER HE
SAID DEFINITELY.
WILL COST MORE MONEY AND WE EVEN
DID SOME RESEARCH ON HOW MUCH A
FROG COSTS.
SO IT YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
INTERESTING TOPIC THIS IS ONE I
STRUGGLED WITH THE WHERE I FALL
AGAIN IT IS THE LOCAL CONTROL
ISSUE.
AND TEACHER AUTONOMY AND ALSO WE
WE SHOULDN'T BE TELLING TEACHERS
EXACTLY HOW THEY CAN OR CAN'T
TEACH WITHIN REASON.
FROM SACRAMENTO [inaudible]
OUR THERE'S ANOTHER IT'S BEEN
BROACHED UPON BUT WE SHOULD.
UNLOCK A CHILD'S INTEREST IN
SCIENCE.
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK
DISSECTION MAY DO SOMETIMES AND
THAT'S A GOOD THING WE MIGHT BE
YOU KNOW.
FACILITATING A CHILD'S INTEREST
IN IN SCIENCE MIGHT WE MIGHT YOU
KNOW THE CHILD MAY ULTIMATELY
FIND THE CURE FOR CANCER.
AND AGAIN WE WE SHOULD SUPPORT
THAT IN IN DISSECTION I THINK.
MAY DO THAT.
AND AGAIN IT MAY NOT BUT AGAIN A
STUDENT CAN DECIDE NOW THERE ARE
OPT OUT PROVISIONS NOW.
AND A LOCAL DISTRICT CAN DECIDE
AS WELL NOW SO.
I I THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING --
WHAT ELSE DO I HAVE HERE I I
ALSO HAVE SOME -- YOU KNOW WHERE
WHERE WHERE I THINK WE SHOULD GO
AS AGAIN STRENGTHENING THE OPT
OUT PROVISION.
AND ALSO MAY BE REQUIRING THAT
THE ANIMAL PARTS.
COME FROM ANIMALS THAT WEREN'T
SOURCED SPECIFICALLY FOR
DISSECTION.
I'M QUITE OPEN IN THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE THAT MAKES
SENSE TO ME.
I THINK THAT HAPPENS SOMETIMES
KNOWN DOESN'T HAPPEN SOMETIMES
NOW -- AND AND AGAIN I I JUST
FALL BACK ON THE LOCAL ARGUMENT.
AND I I THE UNIVERSITY'S.
THROUGH OUR RESEARCH THE
UNIVERSITY'S.
NOT NOT NOT JUST THE MEDICAL
SCHOOLS DO USE.
ANIMALS NOW AND I SECOND THEY
ALSO USE PEOPLE [inaudible]
AND I THINK I I I THINK I'VE
SAID MY PIECE -- BUT I THINK I
REALLY WHERE I FALLS A LOCAL
CONTROL ISSUE THE TEACHER
AUTONOMY ISSUE AND FOR SOMEONE
COOPER SAY IT'S NOT GONNA COST
MONEY YOU CAN JUST DO IT.
I THINK IT'S VERY IRRESPONSIBLE
WE HAVE.
SCHOOLS THAT ARE ALREADY
RADICALLY UNDER FUNDED IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT -- WELL MISS SMITH
ONE SPEAK AYE CULTURES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED I HAVE -- AS A MATTER
OF MY PERSONAL BELIEF SYSTEM AND
WHAT MY OWN CHILDREN EXPERIENCED
IN THEIR SCIENCE COURSE WORK IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
I SEE THE NEED AND I DEFINITELY
SEE THE NEED FOR STRENGTHENING
THE OPT OUT COMPONENT FOR FOR
SURE.
NOW THIS WAS JUST ME DECIDING
ANY ABSENT ANY OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS I THINK I'D BE
TOTALLY THERE WITH YOU BUT AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE EXPRESSED A DO
HAVE.
OTHER CONCERNS ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL ABOUT AND THE AUTONOMY
OF A TEACHER PEDAGOGY IN THEIR
OWN CLASSROOMS AND SO -- I I'M
GOING TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
BECAUSE I I LIKE THE DIRECTION
THAT THIS IS HEADED I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE -- YOUNG STUDENTS LIKE MY
OWN WHO REALLY HAD SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT PERFORMING
DISSECTION HAVE AN OPTION THAT
IS AN EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
THAT IS MEANINGFUL TO THEM THAT
DIDN'T REQUIRE THEM TO STAY IN A
CLASSROOM WHERE THEY FELT VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE ACTIVITY
THAT WAS GOING ON AND FELT THAT
THEY GAINED.
VERY LITTLE KNOWLEDGE FROM THAT
PROCESS JUST BASED ON THEIR OWN
PERSONAL OBJECTION SO.
I THINK THERE ARE AND AS THE
CHAIR POINTED OUT A LOT OF AREAS
THAT I THINK CAN BE WORKED ON
HERE SO -- I I THINK THE AUTHOR
I THINK THE OPPOSITION I HOPE
YOU'LL CONTINUE ALL OF YOU TO
WORK TOGETHER I DO THINK WE'RE
GONNA SEE.
THIS DYNAMIC CONTINUE TO CHANGE
I MEAN WE KNOW ALREADY KIND OF
THE MATERIALS THAT HAVE COME
ONLINE AS WE ADOPTED NEW
CURRICULUM ONCE IN GSS REALLY
STARTS TO UNFOLD IN CLASSROOMS
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT MORE I
THINK.
HANDS ON MANIPULATIVES THAT
SPEAK EXACTLY TO THAT KIND OF
COLLABORATIVE EXPERIENCE THAT I
KNOW YOU WANT YOUR STUDENTS TO
HAVE SO -- THAT SAID I JUST
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION AND
ULTIMATELY LET'S DO WHAT'S BEST
FOR STUDENTS LET'S TO DOCTOR
WILL -- WEBBER'S CONCERNS OVER
EQUITY LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER THESE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
THERE HAPPENING IN ALL OF OUR
CLASSROOMS NOT JUST IN THOSE --
IN IN MORE AFFLUENT AREAS AND
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS IS
MEANINGFUL IN A WAY THAT IT
KNOWLEDGE AND ADDRESSES THOSE.
THE NEEDS OF THOSE STUDENTS WHO
ARE STEM MOTIVATED BUT THEN ALSO
FOR FOR KIDS LIKE MINE THAT THEY
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES STILL THAT
MEANINGFUL SCIENCE EXPERIENCE
WITHOUT BEING SUBJECTED.
TO THE ACTIVITY THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU.
BYE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
MR CALL ARE YOU MAKE CLOSE THE
MOTION IS.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU -- IT JUST ON A COUPLE
OF THE POINTS AS I INDICATED I
DON'T SUGGEST THAT IT'S THAT
IT'S FOR YOUR DOESN'T COST
ANYTHING THERE ARE SOME SOFTWARE
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE FREE BUT
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT.
THERE WILL BE SOME COST INVOLVED
HOWEVER MY CONTENTION IS THAT
IT'S EITHER DEPENDING ON WHAT
TECHNOLOGIES USE EITHER A WASH --
GONNA BE CHEAPER IN THE LONG
TERM BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
NECESSARILY CONTINUE TO BUY AND
PURCHASE -- OF ANIMALS AS YOU DO
WITH ANIMAL DISSECTION.
AND SO.
I I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE COST
FACTOR IS ONE THAT SHOULD
PREVENT GOING FORWARD ON THIS --
I ALSO BELIEVE THE EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE TO BE PARAMOUNT.
AND I THINK THAT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY PEOPLE
MAKE THE STUDENTS MIGHT REMEMBER
THAT THEY CUT INTO AN ANIMAL --
AND MAY BE REMEMBER THAT LESSON
PLAN -- REMEMBER DOING THAT IN
SCHOOL BUT THERE ARE IS THAT THE
ONLY WAY TO BE ABLE.
TO CREATE THAT CRITICAL ANALYSIS
AND TO TEACH THE REALITY IS
AGAIN ALLUDING TO ALMOST THREE
DOZEN STUDIES IT SHOWS
COMPARATIVE OR BETTER OUTCOME
FOR THE STUDENT EDUCATIONALLY.
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON BETTER OUTCOMES THAN ANIMAL
DISSECTION.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT WE GET
ATTACHED TO DOING THINGS A
CERTAIN WAY AND I LOVE TEACHERS
I LOVE THE FACT THAT DISSECTION
HAS BEEN A CRITICAL PART OF MANY
OF THEIR OF OF LESSON PLANS AND
THE WAY THAT THEY TEACH FOR SO
LONG.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE A TIME OR DISSECTION WILL
NOT BE -- OF A COMMON PLACE --
AND I THINK THAT CALIFORNIA'S
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE US IN THAT
DIRECTION AS A STATE AND AS A
NATION -- BECAUSE NOT ONLY IS IT
NOT GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT --
WHEN IN TERMS OF EITHER GOING
INTO COLLEGE THE THE ECOLOGICAL
HABITAT OF ANIMALS OR CERTAINLY
HARVESTING ANIMALS FOR THE
PURPOSES AYE SECTION -- IS NOT
GOOD FOR THE ANIMALS MILLIONS OF
WHICH ARE KILLED EVERY YEAR
NATIONWIDE -- FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DISSECTION AND I DON'T BELIEVE
IS GOOD FOR THE STUDENTS I DON'T
THINK EXPOSING OR OR HAVING --
STUDENTS -- AND THERE ARE SOME
STUDIES THAT SHOW AS MANY AS A
THIRD OF THEM ARE VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE DOING IT BUT DO IT.
THEY DON'T OPT UP EVEN EVEN WHEN
GIVEN THE OPTION BECAUSE AGAIN
BUT A LOT OF FACTORS INVOLVED
INCLUDING HAVING YOUR AT ALREADY
FIGURE.
PUTTING FORWARD A LESSON PLAN --
APPEARS THAT ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AS WELL AS YOUR OWN PERSONAL
DESIRE TO TRY TO ACHIEVE IN
ACADEMICS OF A AS MANY AS A
THIRD OF THE STUDENTS FEEL VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE BUT THEY DO IT.
AND I WOULD ALSO STATE THAT MANY
STUDENTS THAT -- MAY GET SPARKED
INTO SCIENCE -- CAN GET SPARKED
IN MANY WAYS. TO THE
TECHNOLOGICAL OF OPTIONS BUT I
WOULD DOUBT THAT ANY STUDENT IS
GOING TO BE TURNED AWAY FROM
GOING INTO MEDICINE BECAUSE THE
ALTERNATIVES AND THERE ARE
STUDENTS TO GET TURNED AWAY FROM
THE SCIENCES.
BECAUSE OF THE OF HAVING TO
DISSECT AS OF SHIRLEY ABOUT
FINDING SOMETHING THAT SPARKS
INTEREST IN ALL STUDENTS WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON WHAT'S PARK
STUDENTS IN EVERY.
IN EVERY SINGLE STUDENT NOT NOT
AT A PRACTICE OF NOT REQUIRED --
THAT -- THAT DOESN'T -- HAD A
100% THE STUDENTS EITHER
PARTICIPATE OR HAD THAT INTEREST
SPARKED IF THEY GO INTO MEDICINE
TO BE PLENTY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DISSECTION DOES ACTUALLY
CADAVERS AND YOU NAME IT -- BUT
I THINK THAT RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
NOT TO SET A MORAL CENTER BUT I
TECHNOLOGICAL STANDARD AS THE
STATE TO MOVE US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND THE THE THE THE THE OPT OUT
NO DOUBT NEEDS STRENGTHENING BUT
EVEN SETTING THAT ASIDE THE
PRACTICE ITSELF I DON'T BELIEVE
BASED UPON THE RESEARCH IS AS
EFFECTIVE AS THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY ALTERNATIVES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE -- SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BILL
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME
THAT OF ALL THE MEMBERS HAVE
GIVEN -- NOT JUST IN TODAY'S
DEBATE BUT IN LEADING UP TO
TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU -- WE WILL HAVE THE
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
NO [inaudible]
O'DONNELL KILEY.
KILEY KNOWS KALRA AYE.
KALRA HIVE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NOT VOTING SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I A THE BILL HAS THREE
VOTES IT FAILS.
CAN.
WE GET A VOTE ON THE MOON.
IF WE STILL HAVE A WINDOW THE
VOTE ON THE WILL TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
I WILL GO TO OUR VOTE ON MISSILE
MOANS BILL.
AND THAT IS -- FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AB.
TEN SIXTY TWO THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVE I MISS SMITH SECONDED BY
DOCTOR WEBER.
YES -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
AB TENDS IT MISTER KALRA NEWS
AND I KALRA ASHEN -- SIXTY TWO
THE BILL IS OUT HAS SIX WHEELS.
AND I WILL MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE THAT'S THE
CONTENT ON IT'S BEEN MOVED.
IT'S A SECOND MY DOCTOR WEBER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
THREE AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA EYES MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH.
SMITH I AND WEBER [inaudible]
WHERE I?
IT IS SIX VOTED AS OTHER CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT.
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED